You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？够了。足够让我们迷路了！或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Four years after the COVID-19 pandemic upended work life in the U.S., companies and workers are still adjusting to the new normal. In June, APA's annual work in America survey found that many workers
希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要的是优惠，而不是惊喜时。住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为你而住。在新冠疫情颠覆美国职场生活四年后，企业和员工仍在适应这种新常态。6 月，美国心理学会（APA）的年度“美国职场调查”发现，许多员工
are doing well and feeling satisfied with key aspects of their jobs, but some younger workers are struggling. They're more likely than older workers to feel stressed, lonely, and undervalued at work. Today we're going to talk about that as well as other key findings from the survey, which examined some of the biggest issues facing employees and employers today. Why are younger workers struggling? How do employees feel about remote work, hybrid work, and four-day work weeks? How is artificial intelligence affecting the workplace? Are workers using it and are employers prepared to handle the changes it may bring?
工作状态良好，对工作的关键方面感到满意，但一些年轻员工却在挣扎。与年长员工相比，他们更容易在工作中感到压力、孤独和被低估。今天，我们将讨论这一点以及调查的其他关键发现，该调查审视了当今员工和雇主面临的一些最大问题。为什么年轻员工在挣扎？员工对远程办公、混合办公和四天工作制有何看法？人工智能如何影响职场？员工在使用它吗？雇主是否准备好应对它可能带来的变化？
Overall, how are workers feeling about their jobs? and what can employers do to create supportive workplaces where employees can thrive? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Dennis Stolley, Senior Director of APA's Office of Applied Psychology, which focuses on applying psychological science to help solve real-world problems. It looks at areas including the workplace, human technology interaction, and leadership to name just a few areas.
总体而言，员工对自己的工作感觉如何？雇主能做些什么来创造一个员工可以茁壮成长的支持性工作场所？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是美国心理学会应用心理学办公室高级主任丹尼斯·斯托利博士，该办公室专注于应用心理科学来帮助解决现实世界的问题。它关注的领域包括职场、人机交互和领导力等。
Dr. Stolley holds a PhD in social and personality psychology as well as a law degree. He's discussed workplace issues with media outlets including the Washington Post, the New York Times, and CNN.com, and has published widely in both academic journals and popular media. Dr. Stolley, or may I call you Dennis, my colleague, thank you for joining me today. Well, thank you very much for having me. So I mentioned in the introduction that there was an overall trend in this year's work in America's survey that found younger employees are struggling more than older employees feeling undervalued and underappreciated at work. Can you tell us more about that? What did the survey find and
斯托利博士拥有社会与人格心理学博士学位以及法律学位。他曾与《华盛顿邮报》、《纽约时报》和 CNN.com 等媒体讨论过职场问题，并在学术期刊和大众媒体上发表过大量文章。斯托利博士，或者我可以叫你丹尼斯，我的同事，感谢你今天加入我的节目。嗯，非常感谢你的邀请。我在介绍中提到，今年的“美国职场调查”中有一个总体趋势，即年轻员工比年长员工更挣扎，在工作中感到被低估和不被赏识。你能告诉我们更多关于这一点的信息吗？调查发现了什么，以及
why do you think we're seeing this trend? So one of the topics that we asked about in the survey was whether workers felt that their co-workers who were outside their age group appreciated and saw the value in the ideas that they were presenting at work. And what we found was that almost half of the workers who were aged 18 to 25 said no, meaning that they were saying the coworkers outside their age group do not see the value in their ideas. Now, work, it's interesting is when you compare that number to workers who are age 65 and older, among that age group, only 16 percent.
你认为我们为什么会看到这种趋势？我们在调查中询问的一个话题是，员工是否觉得他们年龄组以外的同事欣赏并看到了他们在工作中提出的想法的价值。我们发现，几乎一半 18 到 25 岁的员工回答“没有”，这意味着他们认为年龄组以外的同事没有看到他们想法的价值。有趣的是，当你将这个数字与 65 岁及以上的员工进行比较时，在该年龄组中，只有 16% 的人
said that coworkers outside their age group don't see the value in their ideas. So we see a big difference at the two ends of the working adult age spectrum. Now, the survey also found that younger workers are less comfortable than older workers working outside their own age group, as you said. Why do you think that might be? Well, it's interesting. I have a lot of opinions about that. One of the things about a survey like this one is that the data tells us if something is happening. It tells us how often it's happening, and it can even tell us whether two things are happening together so frequently that it's unlikely to just be a coincidence. But it doesn't ultimately tell us why something is happening. For that, we have to kind of go beyond the data
表示年龄组以外的同事没有看到他们想法的价值。所以我们在工作成年人年龄谱系的两端看到了巨大的差异。调查还发现，正如你所说，年轻员工比年长员工更不习惯与自己年龄组以外的人一起工作。你认为这可能是什么原因？嗯，这很有趣。我对此有很多看法。像这样的调查，其特点之一是数据告诉我们某事正在发生。它告诉我们发生的频率，甚至可以告诉我们两件事是否经常同时发生，以至于不可能是巧合。但它最终并没有告诉我们为什么会发生。为此，我们必须超越数据，
and look at the teachings of psychology as a science and the literature as a whole. And one of the things that I think really may be at work here is the concept of psychological safety. Psychological safety is, it's a term of art that gets used within psychological science, and it refers to the feeling that people have at work that they can truly express themselves and share their ideas and opinions without any negative consequences. And when I say negative consequences, I'm talking about things like, you know, maybe being laughed at for their idea or maybe being belittled for an idea or just ignored for the idea that they're sharing. When people have psychological safety at work,
审视心理学作为一门科学的教义和整个文献。我认为这里真正起作用的概念之一是“心理安全感”。心理安全感是心理科学中的一个专业术语，指的是人们在工作中感到可以真正表达自己、分享想法和意见而不会产生任何负面后果的感觉。当我提到负面后果时，我指的是诸如因为想法而被嘲笑、因为想法而被贬低，或者仅仅因为分享的想法而被忽视之类的事情。当人们在工作中拥有心理安全感时，
they're able to really express themselves. My sense is that among young workers, they may still be developing that sense of psychological safety. And so when they look around, they may be feeling more comfortable working with other people who are in their own age group because that's where they feel safe. And they haven't yet begun to expand their horizons of psychological safety to the entire workforce. What can employers do to help these younger workers get that sense of psychological safety? I think that there are, I can name at least five things that a manager could do that are simple and that you could start tomorrow. One is giving constructive feedback, including for a job well done.
他们能够真正表达自己。我的感觉是，在年轻员工中，他们可能还在培养那种心理安全感。所以当他们环顾四周时，他们可能觉得与自己年龄组的人一起工作更舒服，因为那是他们感到安全的地方。他们还没有开始将心理安全感的范围扩大到整个劳动力群体。雇主能做些什么来帮助这些年轻员工获得那种心理安全感？我认为至少有五件事是经理可以做的，它们很简单，而且你可以从明天就开始做。第一是给予建设性的反馈，包括对出色工作的肯定。
A lot of times I think when we think about constructive feedback, we go right to, well, this is when I have to kind of coach somebody who's made a mistake and I'm going to have to, not offend them, but teach them how to do it right. I think it's so important to go beyond that. When somebody does a good job, even on something very small, to bring that up and celebrate especially with somebody who's new to the workforce. Those little reinforcements begin to give people the sense that, hey, I can make a contribution here and I'm important. And then another thing is to really celebrate teamwork and celebrate collaboration, especially when that teamwork and collaboration spans across the levels of age and experience in the workplace.
很多时候，我认为当我们想到建设性反馈时，我们直接想到的是，这是我必须指导犯错的人的时候，我必须教他们如何做对，而不是冒犯他们。我认为超越这一点非常重要。当某人做得很好时，即使是在很小的事情上，也要提出来并加以庆祝，特别是对于刚进入职场的人。这些小小的强化开始让人们感觉到，嘿，我可以在这里做出贡献，我很重要。另一件事是真正庆祝团队合作和协作，特别是当这种团队合作和协作跨越了职场中年龄和经验的界限时。
Another thing is emphasizing skills over corporate hierarchy. So if there's a young worker who maybe has a job title that is lower down, so to speak, on the organizational chart, that doesn't necessarily mean that they don't have a certain skill. And really celebrating those skills over the corporate hierarchy is another way to just begin to make people feel safe about making their contributions in the workplace. Is it a question of mentorship? Do we find that a lot of workplaces don't value the whole idea of helping the more senior employers to really, really help the younger employers in that way? I believe that it is an issue of mentorship, but it goes beyond just mentorship. So the mentorship is critically important. I think that the one-on-one meetings with managers can be critically important. The relationship between a direct report and a supervisor or manager can be
另一件事是强调技能胜过企业等级制度。所以，如果有一个年轻员工，他的职位在组织结构图上可能比较低，但这并不一定意味着他们没有某种技能。真正庆祝这些技能而不是企业等级制度，是让人们开始感到在职场中做出贡献是安全的另一种方式。这是一个关于指导的问题吗？我们是否发现许多工作场所不重视帮助资深员工真正地、切实地帮助年轻员工的想法？我相信这是一个指导问题，但它不仅仅是指导。指导至关重要。我认为与经理的一对一会议至关重要。直接下属与主管或经理之间的关系
critically important in determining the overall experience that a person has in the workplace, which is yet another thing that our data showed in the 2024 survey over and over again, just how important that direct report manager relationship is. But again, I think it goes beyond just that mentorship to a broader organizational culture. There are some organizations, some workplaces that really foster a culture of everybody matters. And everybody's ideas are important. That doesn't mean that we're going to do everything that everybody suggests, right? But we'll consider it.
在决定一个人在职场中的整体体验方面至关重要，这也是我们的数据在 2024 年调查中反复显示的内容，即直接下属与经理的关系有多么重要。但我再次认为，这不仅仅是指导，还涉及更广泛的组织文化。有些组织、有些工作场所确实培养了一种“每个人都很重要”的文化。每个人的想法都很重要。这并不意味着我们要采纳每个人建议的所有事情，对吧？但我们会考虑它。
And we'll celebrate the fact that you're offering ideas, even if there are ideas that we're going to ultimately reject. And on the other hand, there are some workplaces that really just don't foster that kind of a culture. They are hierarchical and chain of command and people are fearful that if they step out of their small zone, that there might be a negative consequence. Well, let's talk about some of the good news that APA found this year. Many workers are feeling pretty satisfied with key aspects of their jobs. What were some of the areas where employees said they were feeling good about their work? Sure. We saw a lot of positive sentiments.
我们会庆祝你提出想法的事实，即使这些想法最终会被我们拒绝。另一方面，有些工作场所确实没有培养那种文化。它们是等级森严的指挥链，人们担心如果他们走出自己的小区域，可能会产生负面后果。好吧，让我们谈谈美国心理学会今年发现的一些好消息。许多员工对工作的关键方面感到相当满意。员工对工作感到满意的领域有哪些？当然。我们看到了很多积极的情绪。
And we saw them across a range of aspects of the workplace, including things that I think are just deeply important and some things that are more superficial. When I say superficial, I'm talking about things like people generally reported that they were happy with their work schedule. Not that that's not important, but it's superficial compared to, for example, being proud of the work that you do or feeling that you're contributing to society. And that's where I really was happy about some of the numbers that we were seeing. We were seeing 93% reporting that they're proud of the work that they do.
我们在职场的一系列方面都看到了这些情绪，包括我认为非常重要的方面，以及一些比较表面的方面。当我提到表面时，我指的是人们普遍报告说他们对工作时间表感到满意。并不是说这不重要，但与例如为你所做的工作感到自豪或感到你正在为社会做出贡献相比，它是表面的。这就是我真正对我们看到的一些数字感到高兴的地方。我们看到 93% 的人报告说他们为自己所做的工作感到自豪。
86% reporting that they feel that the work they do has a positive impact on society. 81% who would recommend their place of employment as a good place to work. Those are the kind of numbers that really go to the core of our being. You know, why do you get up every day? Because you want to go do work that you're proud of. And it has a positive contribution. And so when I see those kinds of numbers, I feel very good. about the state of the situation.
86% 的人报告说他们觉得自己的工作对社会产生了积极影响。81% 的人会推荐他们工作的地方作为一个好的工作场所。这些数字真正触及了我们存在的本质。你知道，你每天为什么起床？因为你想去做你引以为豪的工作。而且它有积极的贡献。所以当我看到这些数字时，我感觉非常好。关于现状。
One of the biggest shifts in the past four years has been toward remote and hybrid work. What percentage of workers are working remote in person and hybrid these days? And how does work location affect people's job satisfaction? Okay, so these were some really interesting numbers because what we saw is that 59% of the respondents reported that they were working in person. We had 24% reporting that they were working hybrid, some mix of in-person and remote, and 17% reporting that they were working remote. Now, those numbers are mildly interesting on their own,
过去四年最大的转变之一是转向远程和混合办公。如今有多少比例的员工在进行远程、现场和混合办公？工作地点如何影响人们的工作满意度？好的，这些是一些非常有趣的数字，因为我们看到 59% 的受访者报告说他们在现场工作。我们有 24% 的人报告说他们在进行混合办公，即现场和远程的某种组合，17% 的人报告说他们在进行远程办公。现在，这些数字本身就很有趣，
but where it gets really interesting is then we ask the next question of where would you most want to be working? And then we see the numbers break down quite a bit differently, almost an even split of a third, a third, and a third. Now, it's not quite that. It was 38% in person, 34% would prefer a hybrid and 28% would prefer remote. But those numbers are so close to one another that it's almost equal thirds. That's fascinating to me because sometimes I hear people just in casual conversation talk about,
但真正有趣的是，当我们问下一个问题：你最想在哪里工作？然后我们看到数字的分布大不相同，几乎是三分之一、三分之一和三分之一的平均分配。现在，还不完全是这样。38% 的人选择现场办公，34% 的人更喜欢混合办公，28% 的人更喜欢远程办公。但这些数字彼此非常接近，几乎是相等的三分之一。这对我来说很迷人，因为有时我听到人们在随意的谈话中谈论，
well, what's the best way to work? As if there's one correct answer to that. The reality is that different people have different opinions, different personalities, different positions in their life at a given point in time. They might prefer remote work, somebody else might prefer in-person work. That may switch 10 years down the road. And then what's a bit troubling is when you think about the difference between equal thirds versus where people are actually working, we ran the statistics and found that 33%
嗯，最好的工作方式是什么？好像有一个正确的答案。现实情况是，不同的人有不同的意见、不同的性格、在特定时间点有不同的生活位置。他们可能更喜欢远程办公，而另一些人可能更喜欢现场办公。十年后情况可能会发生变化。然后，当你想到相等的三分之一与人们实际工作地点之间的差异时，有点令人不安的是，我们运行了统计数据，发现 33%
of people are not currently working in their desired location, either in-person, remote or hybrid. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all-season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price in valid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. What about four-day work weeks? Are many employers offering them now? Did four-day work week increase employees' happiness at work? Do we know? I don't know that we could say that a lot of
的人目前没有在他们理想的地点工作，无论是现场、远程还是混合办公。你的夏天从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Next Grill 四头燃气烤架开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。用汉普顿湾（Hampton Bay）West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅套装招待整个季节，仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝获得低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请见 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。四天工作制怎么样？现在有很多雇主提供这种制度吗？四天工作制是否提高了员工的工作幸福感？我们知道吗？我不知道我们是否能说有很多
employers are offering four-day work weeks, but there are certainly a meaningful percentage who are. And that number is increasing. So just to give you a sense of the trend, we asked the question in 22, 2022 in our survey of whether or not your employer is offering four-day workweeks. And we had 14% of the respondents say yes. In 23, that number went up to 17%. In 24, that number went up to 22%. So now we're approaching a quarter of the workforce
雇主提供四天工作制，但肯定有相当一部分雇主在提供。而且这个数字正在增加。为了让你了解这个趋势，我们在 2022 年的调查中询问了你的雇主是否提供四天工作制。14% 的受访者回答“是”。在 2023 年，这个数字上升到 17%。在 2024 年，这个数字上升到 22%。所以现在我们接近四分之一的劳动力
who's reporting that their employer is offering a four-day work week. Now, it's still early to be able to know the complexities of how a four-day work week would affect people's happiness and how it would affect productivity. It's going to take a little while for that idea to expand so that we can fully study it. What we can study right now is what people think it will result in. And there we see that 81% of workers who are polled say they believe they could be just as effective at their job if they only worked four days a week. 79% say they'd be happier if they were working only four days a week. And here's what really struck me is 67% of our respondents reported a belief that it is going to become the norm within their lifetime that Americans will work.
报告说他们的雇主提供四天工作制。现在，要了解四天工作制如何影响人们的幸福感以及它如何影响生产力，还为时过早。这个想法还需要一段时间才能扩展，以便我们能够充分研究它。我们现在可以研究的是人们认为它会带来什么结果。在这里，我们看到 81% 的受访员工表示，他们相信如果他们每周只工作四天，他们可以同样有效地完成工作。79% 的人表示，如果他们每周只工作四天，他们会更快乐。真正让我震惊的是，67% 的受访者表示相信，在他们有生之年，美国人每周工作
four days a week. Now, we didn't really dig too deeply into that. So a four-day work week, you may still be working, say, about 40 hours a week, but it'll be spread over four days instead of over five days, right? That's potentially where we're going. Correct. We're not talking about necessarily working fewer hours or switching to a part-time model. And in fact, that's a really important distinction that I'm glad you brought up because there are many people who work four days a week right now and they work just shy of what the law considers to be a full-time job, which then cuts them out of some of the benefits that full-time employees would receive. That's not what we're talking about. The folks who are in that situation are not necessarily
四天将成为常态。现在，我们并没有深入挖掘这一点。所以四天工作制，你可能仍然每周工作大约 40 小时，但它会分散在四天而不是五天内，对吧？这可能是我们前进的方向。正确。我们不一定是在谈论减少工作时间或转向兼职模式。事实上，这是一个非常重要的区别，我很高兴你提到了这一点，因为现在有很多人每周工作四天，他们工作的时间刚好低于法律认为的全职工作时间，这使他们无法享受全职员工应得的一些福利。我们谈论的不是这个。处于这种情况的人不一定
happy about that situation. We're talking about people who are considered full-time employees are getting all the same benefits as a full-time employee, but are putting their work into four days instead of five days. The survey also asked whether employees are using artificial intelligence on the job. What did we find? Are people using things like chat, GPT, and other AI tools, and are employers prepared to deal with this? Yeah, so this is a tricky thing to study,
对这种情况感到满意。我们谈论的是那些被视为全职员工的人，他们获得了与全职员工相同的所有福利，但将工作时间压缩在四天而不是五天内。调查还询问了员工是否在工作中使用了人工智能。我们发现了什么？人们是否在使用 ChatGPT 和其他人工智能工具，雇主是否准备好处理这个问题？是的，这是一个很难研究的问题，
because AI is in some ways everywhere. And it's been around for longer than this. sometimes we may think of it having been around. You know, chat GPT made everyone aware of AI, but it's been around for a long time before that. So there are a lot of workers who use AI, perhaps unknowingly while they're at work. So we didn't want to study that. What we really wanted to do in the survey was get at people who are intentionally using
因为人工智能在某些方面无处不在。而且它存在的时间比这更长。有时我们可能认为它才刚刚出现。你知道，ChatGPT 让每个人都意识到了人工智能，但它在那之前已经存在很长时间了。所以有很多员工在工作中可能在不知不觉中使用人工智能。所以我们不想研究那个。我们在调查中真正想做的是针对那些有意使用
artificial intelligence specifically for the purpose of helping themselves with their work as part of their employment. And when we asked that question, we found that there were about a little over a third who reported doing so at least monthly, many of them much more frequently than monthly. And there were also differences across the type of workers. So we saw that younger workers were using it more. And perhaps that's not surprising. But we also found that younger workers were also more likely than older workers. workers to report being worried that AI may end up taking some or all of their job duties.
人工智能的人，专门用于帮助他们完成工作，作为他们就业的一部分。当我们问这个问题时，我们发现有超过三分之一的人报告说至少每月这样做一次，其中许多人比每月更频繁。不同类型的员工之间也存在差异。我们看到年轻员工使用得更多。也许这并不令人惊讶。但我们也发现，年轻员工比年长员工
So you've got this situation where they're using it more, but they are also more concerned that they may lose some aspects of their job to AI as it progresses and we move into the future. And my understanding is that the survey also found that a lot of these employees reported that their employers didn't have policies in place. Is that right, too? That is absolutely correct. So we asked whether or not, their employer had a policy in place on the use of AI to help them with their work, and only 18% reported that they know that their employer has a policy. 50%, 50% said that their employer has no policy, and 32% said that they are unsure. And so when you look at that
更有可能报告担心人工智能最终可能会取代他们部分或全部的工作职责。所以你面临的情况是，他们使用得更多，但他们也更担心随着人工智能的发展和我们迈向未来，他们可能会失去部分工作。据我了解，调查还发现许多这些员工报告说他们的雇主没有制定相关政策。这也是对的吗？这绝对正确。所以我们询问了他们的雇主是否制定了关于使用人工智能来帮助他们工作的政策，只有 18% 的人报告说他们知道他们的雇主有政策。50% 的人说他们的雇主没有政策，32% 的人说他们不确定。所以当你查看那个
data, it paints a picture of a world in which employees are moving faster. in the adoption of artificial intelligence than perhaps a lot of employer policy manuals are moving. And so there's a bit of a mismatch there. And that's something that I think is clearly going to need to be addressed by employers. Now, the survey also looked at the experiences of workers with physical and mental disabilities and found that on average, they are facing more challenges at work and aren't as satisfied with their jobs. What did the data say? We've talked about a number of things that the data showed that are really positive trends.
数据时，它描绘了一个世界，在这个世界中，员工在采用人工智能方面的速度比许多雇主的政策手册更新的速度要快。所以这里有一点不匹配。我认为这显然是雇主需要解决的问题。现在，调查还审视了患有身体和精神残疾的员工的经历，发现平均而言，他们在工作中面临更多挑战，对工作的满意度也不如其他人。数据是怎么说的？我们已经讨论了数据显示的许多积极趋势。
This is one that is very much not a positive trend. There's a robust and troubling trend throughout our data. And it shows time and time again that people living with a disability, especially people who are living with a non-physical disability, such as a cognitive, emotional learning disability are more likely to report things like having a toxic workplace experience. They're more worried that their salary is not keeping pace with inflation. They're more worried that AI is going to end up taking away some or all of their job duties. In general, there's a trend across so many aspects of the workplace experience where people
这是一个非常不积极的趋势。我们的数据中存在一个稳健且令人不安的趋势。它一次又一次地表明，残疾人，特别是患有非身体残疾（如认知、情感学习障碍）的人，更有可能报告诸如职场经历有毒之类的事情。他们更担心自己的薪水跟不上通货膨胀。他们更担心人工智能最终会取代他们部分或全部的工作职责。总的来说，在职场体验的许多方面都存在一种趋势，即人们
who are living with a disability are just not. doing as well emotionally and psychologically in the workplace as people who are not living with a disability. And we also dug in and tried to ask questions to find out, you know, what could help? And among those who are living with a physical disability time and time again, what they pointed to was access to resources in the workplace that could help them to get their jobs done. They said that's what they need and that's what could help them have a positive impact on their productivity and just generally be a better worker and a better employee. Was there anything in the survey that really surprised you that just jumped out because you weren't expecting it? One of the things that really surprised me is the extent to which the concept of psychological safety just pervaded the entire survey.
患有残疾的人在职场中的情感和心理状态不如没有残疾的人。我们还深入挖掘并试图提出问题以找出什么可以提供帮助。在那些患有身体残疾的人中，他们一次又一次指出的是在职场中获得可以帮助他们完成工作的资源。他们说这就是他们需要的，这就是可以帮助他们对生产力产生积极影响，并总体上成为更好的工人和更好的员工的东西。调查中有什么真正让你感到惊讶的事情吗？有一件事让我非常惊讶，那就是心理安全感的概念在整个调查中是多么普遍。
And again, when I say psychological safety, I'm not talking about, you know, sort of analogous to physical safety. It's not some kind of a hard hat to protect your emotions. Instead, it's this concept that people feel comfortable and safe speaking up in the workplace without fear of negative consequences. And when there's a culture that encourages psychological safety, it has a tremendously beneficial effect. on a lot of things that perhaps you might say, well, that seems reasonable. That makes sense, such as people are more willing to contribute, they feel more like they belong in the workplace, this sort of thing. But it also seems to have a spillover effect into zones where maybe you wouldn't think
再说一次，当我提到心理安全感时，我并不是在谈论类似于身体安全的东西。它不是某种保护你情绪的安全帽。相反，它是一个概念，即人们感到舒适和安全，可以在职场中畅所欲言，而不必担心负面后果。当有一种鼓励心理安全感的文化时，它会产生巨大的有益影响。在许多你可能会说“这看起来很合理，这说得通”的事情上，例如人们更愿意做出贡献，他们更觉得自己在职场中有一席之地，诸如此类。但它似乎也产生了一种溢出效应，进入了你可能不会认为
that psychological safety has anything to do with a person's sentiment about the workplace. To give you a concrete example, people who were reporting a culture of hire, psychological safety at their workplace were also more satisfied with their salary. Now, from this data, we can't say that one causes the other, but we know that they're both co-occurring at a rate that's not just a coincidence and sort of it screams out for additional research on exactly that point. And what a wonderful thing that is, that people who feel safe at work are happier with almost every aspect of their work, even the income that they earn from it. What about for those employees who are struggling with burnout or a toxic workplace?
心理安全感与一个人对职场的看法有任何关系的领域。举个具体的例子，那些报告职场心理安全感文化较高的人，对自己的薪水也更满意。现在，从这些数据中，我们不能说前者导致了后者，但我们知道它们以一种不仅仅是巧合的频率同时发生，这呼吁对这一点进行额外的研究。这是一件多么美妙的事情，那些在工作中感到安全的人对工作的几乎每个方面都更满意，甚至包括他们从中获得的收入。对于那些正在经历倦怠或有毒职场的员工呢？
Are there any things that they can do to cope on an individual level? How can employers help with that? I would focus first on what can an employee him or herself do. And as a first step, I'd suggest that they need to talk to somebody who they can trust. It could be really difficult to work through these kinds of issues by yourself. in isolation. So talking to somebody who they trust, maybe it's a family member, maybe it's a friend, maybe it's a therapist, that can just really help a person process the situation and begin to sort out reality from misperception. And if those conversations are beginning to reinforce a person's
他们可以在个人层面做些什么来应对？雇主如何提供帮助？我会首先关注员工自己能做什么。作为第一步，我建议他们需要找一个他们可以信任的人谈谈。独自处理这些问题可能非常困难。所以找一个他们信任的人谈谈，也许是家庭成员，也许是朋友，也许是治疗师，这真的可以帮助一个人处理这种情况，并开始理清现实与误解。如果这些对话开始加强一个人
feeling that, wow, this work situation that I'm in is actually toxic or it is adversely affecting my emotional and mental well-being, then it might be time to start considering their options. And that can mean a lot of things. It can mean evaluating your own habits or your own habits contributing to this. And what I mean by that is there are folks, and I think we're all guilty of this from time to time, who fall into the trap of obsessively checking our email and our messages and so on, even when it's not necessary, and we know it's not necessary. And if we can break that habit, it could be one small step toward getting out of this burnout trap. But, you know, in some instances, that may not be enough.
的感觉，即“哇，我所处的这种工作环境实际上是有毒的，或者它正在对我的情感和心理健康产生不利影响”，那么也许是时候开始考虑他们的选择了。这可能意味着很多事情。它可能意味着评估你自己的习惯，你自己的习惯是否导致了这种情况。我的意思是，有些人，我认为我们时不时都会犯这个错误，陷入了强迫性检查电子邮件和消息等的陷阱，即使在没有必要的时候，我们也知道没有必要。如果我们能打破这个习惯，这可能是摆脱倦怠陷阱的一小步。但是，你知道，在某些情况下，这可能还不够。
It might be looking beyond their own habits and looking at the workplace itself and asking themselves, is there some way that they can get relief in their current workplace? Is there some way that by talking to their manager, talking to their HR department, raising these issues, they will get some relief, get some looking at their workload, figuring out how they can be happier in the workplace. And in some workplaces, even that may not be possible. And it just might be time to think about exploring other employment options. And certainly I'm not encouraging people to make a rash decisions or put themselves in an untenable economic situation. But it's also untenable to just continue to work year after year in a situation that is harming your own health.
这可能意味着超越他们自己的习惯，审视工作场所本身，问问自己，他们是否可以通过某种方式在当前的工作场所获得解脱？是否可以通过与经理交谈、与人力资源部门交谈、提出这些问题，从而获得一些解脱，审视他们的工作量，找出他们如何在职场中更快乐？在某些工作场所，即使这样也可能是不可能的。那么也许是时候考虑探索其他就业选择了。当然，我不是鼓励人们做出草率的决定或让自己陷入无法维持的经济状况。但年复一年地在损害你自身健康的情况下继续工作也是无法维持的。
Are there lessons that employers can take from the survey? So the number one lesson, when you look at the totality of the results, is that just so many things in the workplace seem to function much more smoothly when you create an atmosphere and a culture where everyone feels safe to express themselves. and to contribute their thoughts and their ideas without any fear. We don't want people to be afraid at work. And so fostering that sense of psychological safety is just absolutely key. And if there's an employer out there who's listening to this podcast
雇主能从调查中吸取什么教训吗？所以，当你审视结果的总体情况时，第一条教训是，当你在职场中创造一种每个人都感到安全、可以表达自己并贡献自己的想法和意见而没有任何恐惧的氛围和文化时，职场中的许多事情似乎运行得更顺畅。我们不希望人们在工作中感到害怕。因此，培养那种心理安全感绝对是关键。如果有一位正在收听此播客的雇主
who is not familiar with the concept of psychological safety at work, I really encourage them to get familiar with it. There are tons of resources available to help employers learn about, what it is and to learn tips for fostering it in their own organization. It's as simple as a Google search to get started on this journey of learning about psychological safety. Now, I have seen personally absolutely no evidence that it does any harm, at least not when it's implemented correctly. And I see lots and lots of evidence that it improves so many aspects of the workplace experience, which ultimately means it's good for the bottom line. And it means it's good for
不熟悉职场心理安全感的概念，我真的鼓励他们去了解一下。有大量的资源可以帮助雇主了解它是什么，并学习在他们自己的组织中培养它的技巧。只需在谷歌上搜索一下，就可以开始这段了解心理安全感的旅程。现在，我个人绝对没有看到任何证据表明它有任何害处，至少在正确实施时是这样。我看到了大量证据表明它改善了职场体验的许多方面，这最终意味着它对底线有好处。这意味着它对
humanity. It's good for the workers. And that's not just at work, but what happens at work spills over into the rest of our lives. It affects us when we're driving home. It affects us once we walk in the door and we interact with our families and with our friends and so on. And if we can make everybody just 10%, 5%, 15% more psychologically safe at work, that's going to spill over and make us all a little bit better in our everyday lives. Now, this is a survey that, APA is doing every year? Have you started thinking about next year? What are some of the areas that you think you might want to be probing? That is a great question. I think that there are a number of things that we want to drill down on a little bit more. I think that the data with regard to
人类有好处。它对员工有好处。这不仅仅是在工作中，而且在工作中发生的事情会溢出到我们生活的其余部分。它影响我们开车回家的时候。它影响我们走进家门与家人和朋友互动的时候等等。如果我们能让每个人在工作中多出 10%、5%、15% 的心理安全感，那将会溢出并让我们在日常生活中都变得更好一点。现在，这是一项美国心理学会每年都在做的调查吗？你们开始考虑明年了吗？你们认为你们可能想要探索的一些领域是什么？这是一个很好的问题。我认为我们想要深入挖掘的事情有很多。我认为关于
physical and non-physical disabilities is striking and troubling, and we need to drill down, not just to learn more about what the problems are, but to begin to try to figure out what are some possible solutions? And how can we really begin to embrace people who are living with a disability in the workplace so that they're achieving the same level of psychological safety that other folks are? I think that we also need to start taking a hard look in the survey about some of the relationships that employees have beyond just their manager relationship, but the relationships that they have with employees in other departments, relationships that they have with HR, what are the levels of trust that they have with an HR
身体和非身体残疾的数据是惊人且令人不安的，我们需要深入挖掘，不仅要了解问题是什么，还要开始尝试找出一些可能的解决方案。我们如何才能真正开始在职场中接纳残疾人，使他们达到与其他员工相同的心理安全感水平？我认为我们还需要在调查中开始认真审视员工除了与经理关系之外的一些关系，即他们与其他部门员工的关系，他们与人力资源部门的关系，他们对人力资源部门的信任程度，
department, with an accounting department, different aspects that are typically found in an average workplace. I think that would just really be interesting to delve into, we're trying to get at what is the experience of working in America? What is the experience of working in America vis-a-vis all of the other co-workers who you tend to interact with throughout the course of your day, your week, year in the workplace. Well, Dennis, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been very interesting, and I'm sure it's going to help our listeners, most of whom I think, have to work.
会计部门，以及在普通工作场所中通常发现的不同方面。我认为深入研究这些会非常有趣，我们试图了解在美国工作的体验是什么？在美国工作的体验与你在一天、一周、一年中在职场中倾向于互动的其他所有同事相比如何？好吧，丹尼斯，我想感谢你今天加入我的节目。这非常有趣，我相信它会帮助我们的听众，我认为他们中的大多数人都必须工作。
Absolutely. Well, thank you so much. I've enjoyed it. If you want to read the full survey and the results, you can find that information on our website at APA.org. Just search for work in America. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology. or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
绝对的。嗯，非常感谢。我很享受这次谈话。如果你想阅读完整的调查及其结果，你可以在我们的网站 APA.org 上找到这些信息。只需搜索“美国职场”（work in America）。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。
And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week.
如果你喜欢你所听到的，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 SpeakingofPsychology@APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。在 Ralph's 享受更多省钱方式，比如每个过道的低价。当你下载 Ralph's 应用程序时，你可以每周通过数字优惠券点击并节省更多。
Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. Seasite for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
此外，你可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑最多可节省 1 美元。在 Ralph's，你每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过储蓄和奖励，每天都能轻松省大钱。Ralph's SoCal 超过 150 年。储蓄可能因州而异。适用燃油限制。详情请见网站。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。